now when president biden finally
announced his ban that you heard so much
about today on russian energy imports he
decided to use the moment to do
something that is disgustingly
washington
shift blame
this is a step that we're taking to
inflict further pain on putin but there
will be cost as well here in the united
states defending freedom is going to
cost it's going to cost us as well
now who's he getting we've been doing
nothing but paying for bidens in his
party's mistakes since he took power
from their insane coveted mandates to
their willful denial of inflation to
their maniacal crusade against fossil
fuels and now
their bungling of u.s foreign policy now
this isn't simply incompetent at this
point it's purposeful i think it's
vindictive
democrats never let a crisis go to waste
we know that and the fact is ukraine
just like the pandemic is another
tragedy for them to exploit in an
attempt to save themselves in the
midterms now you think the country's
going in the wrong direction pain at the
pump well all you need to know it's
russia's fault
can't do much right now
russia's responsible
now this is just one of the many lies
that biden's telling americans who are
suffering under his weak leadership
there's nothing
that a u.s president the most powerful
country in the world nothing he can do
about it nothing
it's all in putin's hands
are we all just imagining our previous
energy independence under trump
well that's what biden wants you to
believe
it's simply not true that my
administration or policies are holding
back domestic energy production
that's simply not true
well except that's precisely what he did
do he halted new drilling
he issued fewer permits
he ditched the big alaska oil project he
suspended leases in anwar and he
canceled keystone xl
now that's what has us really behind the
eight ball now and because solar and
wind don't run america we're more
dependent now on despotic regimes for
energy than under trump
now enter the biden team's genius new
plan
boycott russia buy venezuela
oh that's brilliant
come on but the lies didn't stop where
we stopped them they kept going on like
who's really to blame for the current
predicament we're in
a united response to putin's aggression
has been my overriding focus to keep
all
nato and all of the eu and our allies
totally united today
we remain united we reign united in our
purpose to keep pressure mounting on
putin and his war machine
well false nato is united knighted or
unified only to the extent
that they all wish this didn't happen
it's a terrible tragedy of course they
all agree on that
but nato unity is one of the greatest
illusions ever sold for starters germany
opposes banning russian energy the
netherlands they're not totally on board
and even the uk is wary of immediately
cutting off russian oil and gas
you can't simply close down uh use of
oil and gas uh overnight uh even from
from russia that's that's that's
obviously not something that uh every
country around the world can do
well maybe so but that's biden's fault
too
they could have been buying from us but
biden shut it down and empowered russia
as a major supplier of europe's oil
natural gas and coal
so what would have made us stronger and
freer and by extension make europe
stronger and freer
the democrats wholeheartedly rejected
and that's all on putin
well he's just a beneficiary of our own
self-loathing self-destructive terrible
awful rotten leadership
biden swore to uphold and protect the
constitution of the united states
not
to uphold and protect international
norms global equity climate change and a
border area in a non-nato country
yet the people controlling biden
they know full well that their go green
global agenda requires the resetting of
the american mind away from the old
normal
to a new more compliant kind of normal
so every move they make is designed to
prepare you america
to get used to living with a little less
less travel less privacy less income
less freedom
but when you're pining away for the way
that things used to be
don't blame joe
blame vlad
americans are paying a higher price at
the pump because of the actions of
president putin this is a putin
spike at the gas pump i'm going to do
everything i can to minimize putin's
price hike here at home
who needs a white house press secretary
though when you have a white house press
corps to spend for you
gas is actually less expensive than it
was in 2008 during the previous record
if you take inflation into account we
spoke to one couple who says they say
it's worth paying higher prices right
now
i'm willing to pay higher prices at the
gas i am too i'm willing to sacrifice
and pay for the people that are
suffering ukraine now every single
person that we have spoken to here feels
the exact same way they feel that it's
worth it to pay higher prices if it is
supporting the people in ukraine
oh we'll see in november won't we well
these these are biden propagandists they
would make putin proud they're so good
at their job
now thus when biden drones on about the
cost of defending freedom in ukraine
our own citizens now with everything
that's been happening over the past 14
months
may be wondering about our own freedom
and our own safety at home
because they're seeing life's basic
necessities become increasingly
unaffordable and unattainable meanwhile
they see our southern border becoming
increasingly overrun with migrants and
criminal cartels
but don't think about that no no no
you're not allowed to complain about
anything that is happening here no you
are not because if you do
you're just doing putin's work you're
doing it for him or you do not care
about the suffering of the ukrainian
people you're a horrible person if you
worry about your own country
well we do worry about ukraine but we
also care a lot about what's being done
to our own country by people who will
not stop lying
russian oil will no longer be acceptable
at u.s ports and the american people
will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine
a powerful blow
well the war in ukraine will end when
putin gets the deal he wants and not a
moment sooner
when most of europe is still buying oil
from russia and when china's there to
pick up the slack
our oil sanctions they're not nothing
but they're basically symbolic
finally the venal destructive role our
press is playing here cannot be
overstated
they don't believe that americans paying
higher gas and food prices is a real
sacrifice for them
they believe america has too much
and it's time to reset the american mind
altogether global thinking only please
now despite all their alleged concern
about ukraine the media remain committed
to what we know is just a highly
partisan and divisive agenda that
weakens our country and ends up helping
our enemies
for example they could support more
drilling here at home so would be more
energy independent but they're not going
to
they could dial back some of their
anti-american propaganda that china's
always sighting back at us but they
won't
they could acknowledge that the 74
million people who voted for donald
trump are loyal americans they're not
traitorous fascists
but they're not going to do that they
could hold the bite administration
accountable occasionally for its
mistakes
even if that means the gop might on
occasion benefit not going to happen
they could tell the truth about china
including how it influences u.s politics
don't hold your breath
all of these developments would make
america stronger and thereby put us in a
better position to help ukraine and
defend democracy
but no one really expects the media to
abandon its radical hard left agenda
instead they're going to continue their
civil war against america firsters
and their culture war against everyone
who believes in traditional morality and
of course their propaganda war against
the whole idea of the united states
because like biden like the democrats
they care more about those causes
than they do about ukraine
in fact just like biden himself
their only thing that they're willing to
sacrifice here
is america
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else